Richard Kappas precious hot plants are
only a couple of weeks from harvest this
is the the hot flower this particular
variety is Phoenix and this is what the
Brewers are after inside the hot crane
you see the yellow pollen and that is
what the Brewers need to create the
flavor Richard and his wife Alison have
been growing hops their whole lives and
a farm in the Worcestershire countryside
they have 100 acres dedicated to the
delicate flower enough hops to brew
about 46 million pints of beer hops are
in hot demand thanks to an explosion in
the craft beer industry
that's because craft beers use six times
more hops than beers made by large
corporate Brewers flavor is in bog Stan
and beer is out the craft beer industry
was born in the US over there
hops prices have doubled in the past
decade there's even talk of an imminent
shortage of the flower so the boil is
now finished so the hops that we're just
staring in now are just purely for aroma
three years ago Gary would quit his job
as a solicitor
where is life alone of passion throwing
high-quality craft beer market even in
the in just in London is very different
equivalent Brewers we're now one of yes
within London Gary mostly uses American
hops like lots of brewers hops grown in
the US make up 35 percent of the global
market the UK only produces 1.5 percent
but if these rumors of a us shortage
become a reality Brewers will have to
start looking elsewhere for supply
instead of a new brewery around about
now you may find it very difficult to
get a hold of some of the more popular
hops the market is tightening but there
are plenty of hops available and I think
what we need to encourage craft brewers
to do is to try the full range of
varieties that are available so is a
craft beer drought on the horizon
not likely it might just be a different
breed of hops going into you brew